[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Philip Gorski a professor of
sociology he is a comparative historical
sociologist with strong interest in
theory and methods and in modern and
early modern Europe his empirical work
focuses on topics such as state
formation nationalism revolution
economic development and secularization
with particular attention to the
interaction of religion and politics
other current interest include the
philosophy and methodology of the social
sciences and the nature and role of
rationality in social life
today we'll talk with professor Gorski
about his new book American covenant a
history of civil religion from the
Puritans
to the present welcome professor Gorski
thank you very much Marilyn it's good to
be back okay let's start with an
overview of your book tell us about it
the book is an attempt to recover an
older tradition within American
political culture one that I think at
the moment is sorely needed because it
is a middle way between the two fronts
and the ongoing culture war mm-hmm okay
and what led you to write the book the
idea the civil religion idea was
introduced into American social science
by my doctoral thesis advisor the late
Robert Bellah and I had not I had read
his work as a graduate student obviously
but hadn't really thought much about it
or for that matter that much about
American politics since as you mentioned
in the introduction I really was trained
as a as a European s but I got
interested in it during the 2008
election campaign because I heard echoes
of what Bella had described as
the civil religious tradition in Barack
Obama's political campaign and initially
set out just to write a kind of a deeper
history of Obama's political outlook and
you know as time went on he kind of
faded from being the leading character
to just Supporting Actor in a larger
story which I tried to trace out an
ongoing conversation about the American
project that's been going on since the
foundation of Puritan New England and
continues to the present day and
hopefully beyond the present day as well
okay when you use the term civil
religion what do you mean by that
different people define civil religion
in different ways but I the way I would
put it is that it is the way in which a
particular people thinks about its
political project in a larger or in some
sense transcended frame so doesn't have
to be transcended in the religious sense
it simply has to be transcended in the
sense that it translates the immediate
here now and our particular values and
interests right so relating our polity
our political project to something
larger in the case of the American civil
religion it draws on two different two
different traditions or so I argue in
the book that I call prophetic religion
and Civic republicanism and what I mean
by prophetic religion is the social
justice ethic of the Hebrew prophets you
know the idea that that the nation of
the nation the Thunderer judgment in
some sense not chosen for its virtues
but placed placed under judgment and the
idea of civic Republic is the idea that
the polity is something that's devoted
to the Commonwealth or the common good
that's the literal translation of the
Res Publica
for the Roman term from which we derived
the idea of up the Republic so in this
sense it's about more than just our own
personal self-interest or our own
private dreams but it's something that
transcend that was in some sense and
that's what I mean by civil religion
okay in the preface of your book II
writes some common interpretations of
our shared past are badly in need of
correction what do you mean by that
so I contrast civil religion with two
other ways of thinking about American
democracy one I refer to as as religious
nationalism and that is the idea that
America was founded as a Christian
nation and the implication that of
course that somebody who's not a
Christian cannot be a full member of the
nation I think that's mistaken
so people who claim that the American
founders were Orthodox Christians and
the sense in which some contemporary
Christians would define that sense I
think is deeply mistaken but I also
contrast it with what I call radical
secularism which is the idea that the
American project was based on
Enlightenment values that is also I
think mistaken its mistaken in the sense
that the political tradition that was
most important for the American founders
was not the Enlightenment tradition of
the 18th century but rather this ancient
tradition of Civic republicanism which
goes back through England Italy all the
way to ancient ancient Rome and Greece
and this was a tradition that the
American founders were deeply familiar
with they all read Latin and Greek they
they all had read had read Cicero for
example it was essential thinker here
and so I think both of these
interpretations are finally
fundamentally mistaken and that the way
that we have to understand their
founding values of the United States as
is as a kind of a mix or a hybrid
between
just in secular traditions okay in fact
you do argue that we should take the
middle-of-the-road
do you want to elaborate on that and why
we should do so well III argue that the
culture wars that have been going on in
this country basically for all of my
adult life are in part driven by a
dispute over at the proper place of
religion in in public life and that that
debate has been dominated by religious
nationalists and radical secularists
radical secularists arguing that the
Constitution mandates a total separation
of religion politics which it doesn't
the phrase total separation appears
nowhere in the Constitution that's
interesting
yeah appears nowhere in the Constitution
the Constitution in fact that argues for
the disestablish Albee no established
church but there shall also be free
exercise of religion and those are they
thereby created a kind of a fundamental
tension that's left for us to work out
together collectively I think one can
argue that it mandates separation of
church and state but that's not the same
thing as separation of religion and
politics operation of religion politics
that means that that people cannot speak
in a religious voice in public affairs
even if that is the voice that that is
the one that comes most naturally to
them the one that allows them to
articulate their most deeply held their
most deeply held values but I think I'm
equally equally opposed to this idea of
the United States has founded on
religious nationalism I mean it
guarantee and one of the most
fundamental values in the Constitution
is the free exercise of religion and
that also implies the freedom to
exercise no religion to choose no
religion so central to our understanding
of the American project is religious
freedom and and cultural pluralism and
it's simply something that we have to
accept and come to terms with and not
try to shout down people who come from a
different
perspective than we do right in terms of
your interest in they enter the
intersection I'll call it between
religion and politics we're just coming
out of the election where Donald Trump
is now the president-elect and many
white evangelicals did come out and
supporting them so you know what are
what are your thoughts on that so I
think there's a couple of things that
need to be said the first thing that
needs to be fed is that some white
evangelicals in particular voted for
Trump for pragmatic political reasons
they've become singularly focused on
what I call the pelvic issues abortion
and gay marriage and have been angling
for decades to get a conservative
majority on the Supreme Court and saw
that this was possibly insight and that
if they lost this election it would they
would certainly lose that conservative
majority on the Supreme Court for
generation so that was certainly
prominent in the minds of many Christian
evangelicals who may therefore have
viewed Trump is the lesser of two evils
the other thing needs to be said is that
there were quite a few very thoughtful
and well-known Christian evangelical
intellectuals who came out very
forcefully very early against Trump and
I will simply point to two of them
Russell Moore who works who's an
official for the Southern Baptist
Convention and Peter Weiner who wrote a
number of a very impassioned anti Trump
editorials in the New York Times but
some of the listeners may may have seen
but this still leaves us with a puzzle
the fact is that many American
evangelicals expressed support for Trump
even before he was the only man standing
that that is when people like Jeb Bush
and Ted Cruz who have very good
evangelical bona fides we're still very
much in the race and that that that is
that is a puzzle that I think I can shed
some light on
in the sense that the kind of American
exceptionalism the kind of religious
nationalism that some Christian
evangelicals not all but some embrace
has some strange residences with Donald
Trump's worldview I'll just point to a
couple here one is apocalypticism that
is the idea that the world is going to
going to end imminently and that the
that the end of the world is perceived
by different kinds of natural disasters
by moral decline of course there's
nobody who used the word disaster more
often during the campaign than then
Donald Trump everything was a disaster
and so there this kind of very
pessimistic worldview I think resonated
with an area of residence another I
think somewhat more chilling one was
rhetoric about sacrifice in particular
the need to to make blood sacrifice to
the nation this is a very old idea
within religious nationalism this is
where present-day talk about soldiers
death and battle is the ultimate
sacrifice comes from this goes back not
just to the Civil War but actually all
the way back to the Puritan era and
Trump particularly during the primary
campaigns played on this with a rather
chilling story he spoke
it's an apocryphal story about general
john pershing
who during the conquest and occupation
of the Philippines during world war ii
was reputed to have captured fifty
Islamic terrorists of philippine rebels
and then to have had 50 bullets dipped
in pig's blood and then to have used 49
of those bullets to execute 49 of the
prisoners and then to have given the
50th bullet to the fifth the lone
survivor and sent him back to tell his
people that they should not engage in
terrorism and the applause line is that
there was no
or Islamic terrorism in the Philippines
for 30 years so this idea that there's a
sort of a magical quality to this blood
sacrifice and that blood has to be
spilled to resolve our issues and
maintain maintain our status so this is
another another area of residence last
one it's just that you know Trump often
presented himself in quasi messianic
terms mm-hmm I alone can fix it I alone
can fix it how will he fix it not clear
you simply have to trust in him and and
his powers and there was a lot of debate
about this in evangelical social media
some people said well maybe he's like
King David you know he was all skiing
David was also an adulterer let's not
forget but I think that was a little bit
too much for a lot of people and they
actually compared him to Cyprus the
great who was the Persian Emperor who
delivered that who delivered the Jews
from the Babylonian captivity in the
Bible and so this idea of a kind of a
secular instrument of divine protection
who was sort of cast down the enemies of
evangelicalism this was very widespread
interpretation and kind of theological
justification of the trump presidency
and so there are lots of ways I think
they're not obvious to an outsider you
know in which Trump's rhetoric really
resonated for some conservative
evangelicals despite this sort of
obvious dissonance between his own
personal conduct and evangelical talk
about Family Values it is interesting to
me because I don't think Trump really
you know is not thinking religion when
he's saying the things that he says but
yet people are perceiving his comments
in that regard so I think what has
happened here is that a lot of American
popular culture has taken some of these
themes on board so think about the idea
of the Apocalypse
right this is the post-apocalypse
is is a genre now of movies and comic
books novels conversely some of the some
people may be familiar with the with the
Left Behind series by Tim Tim LaHaye and
a co-author which has also been turned
into films and this is basically a
transformation of a particular
evangelical understanding of the end
times into you know kind of a Tom Clancy
style thriller even I think climate
change feeds into that absolutely
apocalyptical kind of ending absolutely
ok and turning and getting back to the
book the history of civil religion from
the Puritans to today has there been a
big change
in civil religion through those years or
has it been pretty much predominantly
the same I mean some of the things that
you're speaking about for Trump you know
you can look back to the Puritans and
find some of those very same things so
is it true that it's pretty much gone
unchanged or has there been a lot of
different changes that it's gone through
so it has it has grown and transformed
over over the course of American history
and I'll just give two examples of this
so you know I already mentioned that one
of the essential values that enshrined
in the Constitution and is the idea of
religious freedom right but there were a
lot of qualifications and provisos on
what that would mean this was probably
most obvious and kind of anti-catholic
sentiment during the 19th century up
into the early 20th century I think many
people today probably don't realize what
an enormous thing it was when John F
Kennedy I'm a practicing Catholic
became the President of the United
States that was something which would
have really been impossible even in the
in the early 20th century when a
Catholic Al Smith ran for the presidency
and was soundly defeated after a kind of
a rabid anti-catholic campaign so you
know part of it is understanding a
broader understanding of religious
freedom is something that doesn't just
apply to Protestants or to Christian the
other thing I would really point to as
an example of how it's grown and evolved
is our understanding of equality so you
know we all know the the famous words
and that you know the preamble to the
Declaration about all men created equal
and we also know that the Constitution
violated or broke with that promise by
declaring tacitly at least that an
African slave was only 3/5 of a person
and it took took a civil war and a civil
rights movement for people to fully
understand that equality had to mean
racial equality and not just the
Equality of white property holding men
and obviously you have to put the
software Jets into that story there as
well movement of the 1960s so you know
it even if we sort of agree on what our
values are I think that we sometimes
blind ourselves to with that what they
actually imply or mean for how we should
what are our lives together
so ultimately what would you like the
reader of your book to take away what
lesson I guess at the you know at the
moment I think the other special
importance our two ideas one is the the
idea of civility which comes out of
civil religion and civility means at a
minimum that we engage with one another
with a certain degree of trust and
openness and
respect and these are all things which I
don't need to tell anybody here are
sorely lacking after this latest this
latest electoral campaign which has not
only sown and deepen divisions of race
and a party but divisions that are even
now cutting through and dividing
families you hear stories of people on
friending one another on Facebook I read
this morning as to worry about people
disinviting relatives for Thanksgiving
because of divisions over this election
and here I do really lay a lot of the
blame at the feet of Donald Trump for
violating the most obvious norms of
civic discourse and even human decency
that's one thing and the other thing is
that the notion of that I that's
important to the book is the notion of a
vital Center and what I mean by a vital
Center is not at some kind of political
consensus where we all agree about what
equality and freedom mean and how you
balance those two things with one
another but what I mean by that is a
basic commitment to those things as
values that make us a people and without
which will no longer be a people without
which there will no longer be American
democracy in any meaningful sense
I mean without that sort of basic level
of agreement it's not possible for us to
have meaningful disagreements and that
is increasingly what you see debate just
devolves into trading insults shouting
matches demonization mutual
recrimination you know I really really
fear for the future of the American
Republic at the present moment right
well I think you have your work cut out
for you over the next four years and
evaluating what happens and I think if
you're being on the show thank you very
much Fallon
for more information about Professor
Gorski and his research please visit our
website at Macmillan report dot edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
[Music]
you